mr safari thank you for joining dw
now jordan is seen as such a beacon of
stability in the middle east uh
has very close ties with germany even uh
hosting german troops
there but it faces of course enormous
challenges um
top of the list being the vast number of
refugees that it houses and then of
course we have a pandemic on top of that
over the past year is jordan getting the
international support that it needs
thank you so much and and it's a
pleasure to be with you uh
we've been at the receiving end of every
crisis in the region
uh and yet we remain committed to our
principles of working for peace working
for stability because we do believe that
unless we're able to create
a regional and indeed a global
environment of peace and stability none
of us will be able to
move forward towards meeting our our
number one goal which is creating a
better lives for all our people
refugees is among one of the many
challenges that
jordan faces and in germany in
particular we have a solid partner
our relationship is strategic in the
bilateral sphere we're working very very
closely to each other
on bilateral issues and also vis-a-vis
regional issues where we have a common
interest again of resolving regional
crises and
and finding horizons for peace stability
and therefore
prosperity germany has been a solid
partner for us
supporting our economic development
so we're working closely together
encountering
terrorism and extremism we're
coordinating very closely in efforts to
resolve the palestinian-israeli conflict
addressing the syrian crisis
all these are common challenges which no
one country can do
deal with on its own indeed in jordan
we are facing tremendous challenges the
support of partners like germany is key
to that in relation to the refugees
file in particular
germany has been solid and in supporting
us and support
supporting us help the refugees and
supporting the refugees then
themselves that said however what we
need to emphasize is that
refugees cannot be the responsibility of
host countries only
it is a global challenge and therefore
the solution has to be global
we do appreciate the tremendous support
that we
got from our partners in europe and the
us and others
but we also must drink the alarm that we
are
witnessing dwindling resources towards
supporting the refugee issue and that is
dangerous because it does impact first
and foremost refugees themselves
and host countries abilities to provide
them the decent
dignified life that they need so in
german
with german in particular we have a
strategic relationship continued
cooperation
and discussion between his majesty and
the chancellor between me and my
counterpart minister hais we have an
institutional
cooperation that is proceeding extremely
well in both bilateral and towards
regional issues
but refugees again is a global challenge
we need to work together
because investment in refugees is really
is investment in our collective security
i i i'd like to ask a specific question
though about support uh
in in the current situation because on
top of the refugees you have the
pandemic
um and jordan has been praised for
providing refugees with vaccinations
um but jordan is getting a rather small
number of vaccinations from the
international
community if we look at the kovacs
system that has been set up in the first
allocation from kovacs jordan is getting
around 440 000 doses
that's barely more doses than have been
administered
in berlin just a single city um your
population is more than 20 times that
you have refugees as well
do you feel that it's not really enough
obviously the number of doses we've
gotten
thus far is not enough we're working
extremely hard on trying to get
the amount that we need to uh vaccinate
our population
and vaccinate everybody who is in jordan
in
dealing with with the vaccination issue
we're treating everybody in jordan
equally
we were the first country to vaccinate a
syrian refugee
we're committed to doing that uh however
there is a challenge we're talking to
everybody
with a view to ensuring that we get the
vaccines we're trying to get the
all vaccines that are that are out there
uh that's an ongoing process
unfortunately there is
more uh demand than supply that when it
comes to vaccine there's a disruption in
the supply chain
we're trying very very hard to address
that and our commitment is to vaccinate
our people and to vaccinate everybody
who is
injured but are you disappointed that
western countries
are prioritizing their own populations
to such a massive extent compared to
supporting
uh organizations like none of us is safe
until all of us are safe i mean
the the the virus doesn't know borders i
think the experiment
the experience that we had with with the
vaccine has shown how
interconnected we are so as such
we do believe in multilateral work to
address this challenge
we're going to continue to work with our
partners to make sure that we get the
vaccination
it must be a global commodity everybody
must have equal access to that to this
vaccine
because again unless we are able to
achieve the immunity for the global
population
the risk of the vaccine coming as
is there in jordan we had initially we
had a good run
with during the first wave of the
vaccine of course
that came at a very high price because
we imposed a lock down
obviously we cannot do that again our
economy cannot sustain that so what
we're trying to do is to establish a
balance between protecting the people
and protecting the livelihoods of the
people and that's a very difficult
balance to maintain
yet again we must all realize that we
need to work together uh
uh efficiently in order to be able to
overcome this global challenge
i mean you've also received a large
number of doses of the sino-farm vaccine
your own prime minister reportedly
received the sign of farm vaccine did
you receive that also yourself
we have a a a program that is
aiming to vaccinate everybody cynofarm
is a vaccine that we're trying to get we
haven't gotten the
amount that we need yet so we are in
talks with the chinese government to try
and get more of that
we're also in talks with astrazeneca
with
also in talks with with with russian
government to try and get
sputnik we're also in talks with the
visor moderna so pretty much uh we're
knocking on every door that is out there
to try and and get the vaccine again
to be able to vaccinate our population
and and and
get over this endemic obviously are you
concerned about
you know this this issue of vaccines
turning into a little bit of a
geopolitical battlefield that
uh you know there's concern in the west
that the russians and the chinese
are kind of uh crowding in bringing
their vaccines when western supplies are
failing do you do you observe that
yourself
look i i mean again this is a global
challenge uh
we the number one priority is to ensure
that we protect the safety of our people
we do not want this to be politicized
this is a humanitarian issue this is a
health issue
and therefore we are aware of the
tremendous challenges with the with the
with the
supply chain i think everybody is trying
to address that
again as far as jordan is concerned we
are going to get every vaccine that is
whose use is authorized by our health
authorities is a vaccine that we
we should get we do not want to
politicize this issue
nobody will benefit from politicizing
this issue i think we have enough
politics to deal with this is a this is
a an area where
politics should not be a factor what
should be a factor is
ensuring that we all protect our
citizens because again
unless all our citizens are protected
none of our citizens
is safe that has been the experience
with the vaccine
a lot of our countries have seen an
improvement in the cab and then suddenly
over a period of one week or two weeks
the curve goes up again why because the
vaccine comes you know through the
exchanges that we cannot disrupt no
country can lock itself away from the
rest of the world and therefore
it is imperative that the vaccine issue
remains within the realm of the
of the health issue and politics cannot
and should not become a factor
um but the fact is that we do see china
for instance
uh taking a much more uh active role in
the middle east
you yourself co-hosted a forum with wang
yi just last year
to talk about greater chinese in
engagement in the middle east
some observers look at a kind of a big
trend with the united states pulling
back in the middle east and china coming
in is that something you observe
well um the us has a leading role in in
the middle east and and that role cannot
really be
replaced at this point europe has a
leading role in the middle east the
middle east has been
has been unfortunately a an area where
conflicts have continued to grow and
expand uh unless we work together as
partners we're not going to be able to
resolve those issues
china does have a strong economic ties
with the region
not much with jordan but regionally
speaking
there is a a lot of economic cooperation
trade cooperation purchase of oil and
all of that so
uh that is a reality but as far as
jordan is concerned we
always see good relations with everybody
based on
our you know international law on our
values where we want cooperation rather
than conflict where
we want relations to be transparent and
based on
on grounds that allow for a mutual
benefit for all
i'd like to return to the question of
refugees you know
jordan is hosting many hundreds of
thousands of syrian refugees
um at the moment you said today that it
it's not yet possible for them to return
um but have you been having discussions
with the syrian government about
the possibility at some point of
returning
look again we have 1.3 million syrians
in jordan about 662 000 of them are
registered with the unhcr the rest are
not
only 10 percent of of of this number
live in refugee times the rest are all
over the country
our long-standing position in jordan is
that
we need to provide those people with a
dignified life
if you provide them with education if
you provide them with a with a decent
life
then there will be the the people who
will rebuild their country once the
conditions are conducive for them to go
back
if you abandon them to hate and despair
and and and ignorance
then the challenge is going to be
enormous for all of us so
our policy do everything we possibly can
for them until
uh conditions are ripe for them to go
back now
before covered we had reopened our
borders with syria
the number of those who went back did
not exceed 50 000
because ultimately the decision to go
back is going to be made by refugee
families
i think a family of refugees are going
to be sitting together over dinner
and discussing do we go back or do we
not go back and i think the answer is
going to depend on whether
they're certain that they'll be safe
that they'll be secure that they'll be
schools for their kids jobs for for for
their
bread earners if that is the case
they'll go back if not they will not go
back
thus far uh uh not many are going back
not many are expressing a willingness to
go back because
unfortunately efforts to bring about a
political solution to the crisis
has not yet reached a satisfactory
conclusion
conditions on the ground are not
improving either
so if you're a refugee family in jordan
or anywhere else
you're not going to go back unless
you're certain you're going to have a
good life
going back home so as such the challenge
remains with us
not many are going back and until then
i think it is incumbent upon all of us
to make sure that we
address the needs of those refugees
because if we do not
we're having a situation where we're
failing
people and where the challenge will
continue to grow in the future and that
will
face all of us and if i may say here
that again
migration is a global challenge europe
is certainly concerned about that and
if we are not able in the region to meet
the needs of refugees
they will be looking at at other places
where they can
have their needs met so i think it is in
our strategic interest all of us to make
sure that we
come together work together uh to
provide refugees with the decent life
that they deserve
until they're able to go back thus far
we are not seeing a lot of interest
by refugees to go back and despite that
the fact that there still is no real
political settlement
in syria the syrian regime now does look
uh secure it's basically one um
the united arab emirates has been
calling now the foreign minister your
counterpart
for syria to return to the arab league
do you agree with that
look i i don't think that's exactly what
what
our emirati brother have said what they
said is that ultimately
uh uh syria needs to restore its peace
stability
uh and and resume its role in the region
what we believe
is the priority right now is to proceed
with political efforts to find a
political solution to this crisis
because obviously there's no military
answer
to it to be quite honest with you we
have not really had a comprehensive
strategy
to dealing with the crisis over the past
years it's about time we stopped
reassessed and said where do we want to
go
is the current strategy working or not
and ultimately the goal
needs to be to solve the crisis and we
need to remember that the syrian crisis
must and is about syria and the syrian
people
and yes the crisis has been globalized
there are many conflicting agendas
regional and global there but the bottom
line is
we have to solve this crisis if we do
not we all are going to pay
even heavier uh a price than we have
thus far
uh millions of syrians have been
displaced
either as idps or or as as refugees
there was a recent report by the warning
against
the fact that millions of syrians do not
have food security
a whole generation of syrians are
growing up without school without
without education without
proper services all this is a recipe for
a future disaster
what we need to do is again uh focus
all our efforts on trying to bring about
a political solution that will preserve
the unity
of syria that will restore to its safety
and security
that will ensure the enduring defeat of
terrorists
and that will create conditions
conducive for for refugees to to return
that must be the
the focus and that's where we're working
with partners including with germany
to make sure that we have uh horizons uh
towards that solution but i just want to
make sure i understand you there
so you saying between the lines that you
don't feel that syria should return to
the arab league at this point that that
should only happen once there's a
political
solution look i i believe syria's return
to the arab league is part
and parcel of the bigger problem we need
to make sure that syria resumes its rare
role in the region but as we do that we
must look at the comprehensive
crisis ultimately crisis has to end
syria has to regain its safety and
security people have to
regain their right to a dignified life
and syria must resume its role including
going back to the arab region and what's
incomprehensible to be honest
is the absence of a collective arab role
in in in in efforts to
bring about and into this crisis it is
incomprehensible unacceptable that
everybody is on the table except a
collective arab arab effort so
what we're discussing with with all our
partners is how do we
all come up with a strategy that would
deliver an end to this humanitarian
disaster to this
to this catastrophe in syria
and everybody needs to do their to do
their their
their part in that and we are countries
after the syrian people are the most
affected by the crisis and therefore it
is only logical that we
assume a collective part in efforts to
bring about and into this crisis
i'd like to turn to the israeli
palestinian conflict which is obviously
a big
part of your visit to germany and france
this week
now of course the ground has shifted
there somewhat in the last year we've
had the abraham accords with various
gulf
estates making peace with israel
jordan made peace with israel many years
ago of course
do you feel that jordan has been somehow
sort of overtaken by these other
countries
uh making these accords with israel do
you feel that they have
given israel a free pass on what you
described earlier today as a very
dangerous situation there
look we've had a peace treaty with
israel for almost 27 years
peace is a strategic choice for jordan
indeed for
the whole arab and muslim world and it
is a necessity for
regional and global security as such we
continue to do everything we possibly
can to achieve that
just and lasting peace but in order for
peace to be lasting in order for peace
to be accepted
it has to address the legitimate rights
of the palestinian people
in a way that ensures fulfilling those
those rights and particularly
their right to freedom and statehood on
the basis of the two-state solution so
that you see
an independent sovereign palestinian
state emerging on
1967 uh alliance with the occupied
jerusalem as capital to live in peace
and security
with israel this is the only answer to
the problem and this is the
collective sort of decision of the
international community the two-state
solution
is the only solution going forward that
said
no peace treaty between israel and arab
countries including the peace treaty
with jordan can be
a substitute for palestinian-israeli
peace
and therefore the core issue is the
palestinian-israeli conflict we want to
resolve this conflict because this is
how we ensure
that we get the comprehensive piece that
we all need and
and and are are working to realize
our role uh continues to be uh strong
to be proactive and again we're working
with all our partners in coordination
with the palestinians in coordination
with the rest of the arab world
to make sure that we create the
necessary horizons for
for progress on that on that track but
yet again
i want to emphasize that the core issue
is the palestinian-israeli conflict no
number of peace treaties will produce
the comprehensive piece that we seek
unless
that issue is addressed in a way that
again
ensures the implementation of the two
state solution right now that solution
is under tremendous danger
uh unilateral measures are compromising
the viability of that two-state solution
settlement building settlement expansion
is something that
we continue to warn against because it
does
undermine the
formula upon which the whole peace
process was launched
many years ago and that is the land for
peace formula so
uh we continue to work we continue to do
everything we possibly can
to make sure that we move towards the
solution and we protect
the viability of the two-state solution
and and and in this effort we do work
with
all our partners and friends and
tomorrow we'll be meeting with
our partners in the munich group that
includes germany egypt and france
and and what we're trying to do is again
emphasize that the status quo cannot
continue
the danger inherent in the status quo
is serious and time for action
is now because we do not have any time
to lose
of course we have elections coming up in
both israel and in the palestinian
territories you know this deadlock has
occurred under the current leadership
would you like to see a change of
leadership in israel and in the
palestinian territories
look it's not for us to decide you know
the leadership of either country i mean
it is
it's the people who they're people who
will
make that choice but what we'd like to
see is a commitment to
the peace process what we'd like to see
are actual measures that would
allow us to have progress in in
restoring negotiations that can deliver
the two-state solution
and what we'd like to see is is
everybody realizing that
unless we achieve the two-state solution
we are
risking the future stability of the
whole region because if you
if you kill the two-state solution the
only realistic alternative that remains
is a one-state solution and one state
solution the big question that
we're all going to have to grapple with
is that is it going to be
an institutionalized upper third or is
it going to be
a democracy where palestinians have full
political rights so
what we'd like to see is genuine
effort by everybody to do what's right
for everybody
which is moved towards a just and
comprehensive peace because
nobody is doing anybody a favor by
opting for peace it is a necessity it is
a need for all
and without an active international role
we cannot really achieve that piece so
the role that europe is playing and has
been playing uh
is is extremely important and we also
look forward to engaging with the
u.s administration because it does have
a leading role in all those efforts and
we look forward in jordan for all of us
to come together and send the right
messages to all the parties that
the only way to move forward is to go
back to the table
and discuss how do we move towards the
two-state solution on the basis of
an international law so that everybody
can have their rights and concerns
addressed and that
everybody in the region will have the
right to live in peace and uh
to to seek prosperity and to seek
development forward
of course we have the 10th anniversary
of the
syrian war around us it's a time where
people are reflecting
on the arab uprisings how do you feel
in retrospect about how that era turned
out
again ultimately you what we want
is as is for all of us in the region to
be able to move
uh uh on the basis of solid clear
programs that would deliver
the best for our people our
responsibility as governments is to
ensure the best life for our people
that said economic reform is important
political reform is important
in jordan we are fully committed to uh
doing everything we possibly can to
ensure that we have
a better governance that we that we move
ahead with the reform programs his
majesty was very very clear
including in the latest letter of
designation to the new government that
this is a priority and we need to move
forward so ultimately i think
what we enjoyed and believe is that
those reforms
are necessary for us for our future
we're committed to them and we're doing
everything we possibly can to move
forward
of course a regional environment does
have an impact
but we should mitigate against that and
we are mitigating against that
uh ultimately the middle east
has more than its share of crises that
are impacting our people
our our the ability of our people to
realize their potential and this must
stop and this we do by again
moving forward with uh solving those
regional crises that are having a
disastrous impact in in many parts of
our world
and also to move ahead with reforms that
will ensure with we have the best
most efficient uh system of governance
so that we can move forward and address
those reforms and address those needs
but those reforms of course happen
within the context the final question
about of jordan as a constitutional
monarchy do you see
and would you like jordan to remain that
do you think it will remain that forever
would you hope in your heart of hearts
that maybe one day
it will be possible for jordan to become
a fully fledged democracy
well again define full-fledged democracy
we are we believe we are
a country that has enjoyed stability
that has enjoyed moderation that has
respected the rights of its people it's
never perfect but that's an ongoing
process and we do everything we possibly
can
the monarchy is the key stabilizing
factor in jordan it's a monarchy that
has the
support of the people it's a monarchy
that has
been working extremely hard to ensure
that we deliver the best
future for our people so democratic
reforms are are something that are
in the core of of division of his
majesty for us to move forward and we're
continuing
uh with that ultimately there are
different systems of government the
bottom line is
is the system of government delivering
the best for its people is it respecting
their rights
is it moving forward to creating better
horizons we believe in jordan we're
doing that challenges are many
we do not say that the situation is
perfect we say yes we have a lot of
challenges
but we're working extremely hard to make
sure that we
address them and i think in jordan in
particular as i said we are at the
receiving end of every crisis in the
region so
uh what's happening in the region does
have an impact on all our efforts
yet we do not give up we try and
continuously to adjust our policies and
our programs to make sure that we move
towards our
final goal that his majesty has set as
an objective for us which is to
move in democratic reforms create
horizons
address whatever deficiencies that we
have in our
in our legislation and implementation of
those legislation
and move forward towards the best future
that we can provide for for our people
but it sounds like you really mean never
actually pick
people could never pick their own habit
ahead of state in jordan is that not
something that you might dream of in the
distant future
look we are extremely happy with the
system of government that we have
again jordan will be celebrating 100
years since the establishment of jordan
and the coming next month and we look at
what we've done in jordan in a region
that has been plagued with crisis and
conflicts and wars and i think thank god
we
we can say proudly in jordan that we've
been able to overcome many of those
crises
due to the fact that we have a
leadership that has the support of the
people
a leadership that is committed to reform
a leadership that is
moderate open to
dealing with all the challenges in an
effective
way based on our values of moderation
and openness and respect and
and committed to moving ahead with the
democratic reforms that are necessary
for
our country and that will increase our
ability to
do better on every aspect of life so
ultimately
this is a system of government that we
have had since jordan
became a state over 100
almost 100 years ago we are committed to
that it's a it's a regime that
a system of government that has the
support of the people and we're moving
forward and as such we are
we're happy with what we have and we are
in a continuous process of uh
reforming our legislation introducing uh
uh economic and and and
and political reforms that will
render our ability to serve our people
more effective and more efficient mr
saudi many thanks for speaking to us
thank you sir
you